Don’t miss out.
>> Sandra: UTAH SENATOR MITT
ROMNEY WITH STRONG ROADS FOR
ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS BLASTING THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
CRISIS AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> WHAT I FIND ASTONISHING WE
HAVE THE SECRETARY RESPONSIBLE
FOR SECURING OUR BORDER AND
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM WHO DOESN’T
RECOGNIZE THESE CHARGES BEING A
PROBLEM AND THEY ARE HUMAN
BEINGS BEHIND THESE NUMBERS.
IT’S NOT SAYING WE HAVE TO MAKE
CHANGES IMMEDIATELY.
I FIND THAT -- I FIND THAT
EXTRAORDINARY AND EXTREMELY
DAMNING.
>> MAYORKAS SAID THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN MEET THE
CHALLENGE ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER AND BLAMED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE MASSIVE
SURGE HAPPENING THERE.
>> Bill: OUR NEW GUEST SHARING
PICTURES OF THE CRISIS.
IT SHOWS DRUGS AND MIGRANTS
STUFFED INTO SEMI TRUCKS AT THE
BORDER AND VIDEO THAT SHOWS
MIGRANTS DRIVING BY TROOPERS
WHO STOPPED ANOTHER CAR.
LIEUTENANT CHRISTOPHER
OLIVAREZ, TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE FIRST IMAGES I WANT TO
SHARE AND EXPLAIN IT TO US.
IT IS A SEMI TRUCK AND INSIDE
YOU FOUND 105 ILLEGALS AND 171
POUNDS OF MARIJUANA.
WHAT HAPPENED THERE?
>> YES, BILL, GOOD MORNING AND
THANKS FOR HAVING ME AGAIN.
ONE OF THOSE PHOTOS YOU ARE
SEEING THERE DPS TROOPERS ARE
STOPPING THAT COMMERCIAL
VEHICLE WHICH RESULTED IN 105
MIGRANTS STUFFED INSIDE THAT
TRAILER.
THAT WAS JUST GREAT WORK BY DPS
TROOPERS.
AS WE APPROACH THE SUMMER HEAT
WE KNOW THAT SMUGGLING OF THESE
MIGRANTS IN VEHICLES AND
VEHICLES SUCH AS A COMMERCIAL
VEHICLE IS HIGH RISK AND
DANGEROUS.
GOING BACK TO THE OTHER PHOTO
WHERE WE SHOW THE NARCOTICS
WITH MIGRANTS.
THE CARTELS ARE ALSO SMUGGLING
MIGRANTS ACROSS AT THE SAME
TIME SMUGGLING NARCOTICS AS
WELL TRYING TO USE IT AS A
DISTRACTION FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> Bill: HAPPENING ALL THE TIME.
EVERY DAY, IN FACT.
GOT A FEW VIDEOS NOW.
THE FIRST ONE IS THE TROOPER
THAT GOES TO PULL A CAR OVER.
WHEN IT STOPS THE ILLEGALS GET
OUT AND RUN AWAY.
ANOTHER VIDEO SHOWS SMUGGLERS
TRYING TO GET OTHER PEOPLE INTO
THEIR VEHICLES.
EXPLAIN THOSE, SIR.
>> YES, THE FIRST VIDEO WITH
DPS TROOPER STOPPING A VEHICLE
IS ON A MAJOR HIGHWAY.
ONE OF THE PRIMARY HIGHWAYS
TAKE LEADS TO THE PORTS OF
ENTRIES IN THE RIO GRANDE
VALLEY AND IT LEADS TO HOUSTON,
DALLAS, SAN ANTONIO.
THIS COUPLE CAME DOWN FROM THE
HOUSTON AREA WITH THE SOLE
PURPOSE TO SMUGGLE MIGRANTS TO
HOUSTON.
IT IS ADVERTISED ON SOCIAL
MEDIA.
THE TROOPER WAS THERE AT THE
RIGHT TIME AND ABLE TO RECOVER
THE MIGRANTS AT THAT TIME.
ARRESTED THE DRIVER AND FEMALE
PASSENGER FOR SMUGGLING.
>> Bill: KEEP IT CLEAR.
ANOTHER VIDEO.
SMUGGLERS USING TO GET PEOPLE.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WHAT HAPPENED HERE, SIR?
>> WE HAVE A SMUGGLER WHO IS
PRETTY MUCH BOLD IN WHAT HE IS
DOING AND ADVERTISING AND
SHOWCASING HIS CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY ON SOCIAL MEDIA BY
DRIVING BY A TROOPER WHO WAS
STOPPED WITH ANOTHER VEHICLE
AND SHOWCASING THAT HE IS
SMUGGLING MIGRANTS INSIDE HIS
VEHICLE AS HE DRIVES BY THE
TROOPER SO THAT’S VERY BOLD FOR
THOSE SMUGGLERS TO SHOW THAT
ACTIVITY POST IT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA.
>> Bill: CERTAINLY IS.
HAPPENS EVERY DAY, DOESN’T IT?
FOR HOW MANY LONGER.
>> IT IS NOT SLOWING DOWN, BILL.
IT WILL CONTINUE TO INCREASE.
THE NUMBERS SHOW IT AND WE’RE